Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Sag mal, sollten Podcaster nicht auch vorzeitig geimpft werden, dann wächst auch das Vertrauen in der Bevölkerung.
Ja, aber nur, wenn was übrig ist.
Politik Nummer dreihundertundeinundachtzig vom, was haben wir denn heute? Fünfzehnter Februar zwanzig einundzwanzig. So sieht's aus, ein Montag, die haben wir uns jetzt ausgesucht.
Der Montag soll's sein, am Anfang der Woche schon mal die Stimmung in den Keller ziehen. Äh aber wir wir haben uns ja wir müssen ja erstmal, müssen wir ja hier das Vertrauen der Bevölkerung steigern, ist ja unser Ziel, ne.
Das tun wir das nicht laufend.
Es ist auf jeden Fall Vorbilder.
Her mit her mit der Impfspritze.
Wir wollen uns nicht vordrängen, aber.
Wir wollen ja auch ein gutes Vorbild abgeben.
Ich finde das so unsäglich, wirklich. Ich könnte ins Essen kotzen. Wenn ich diese ganzen,
wichtig Tour sehe, die sich davor impfen lassen, ne? Und wenn ich dann noch diese, also wie lustig das auch ist, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, ähm, bereitwillig so dieses Ablenkungsmanöver,
gefressen wird. Ja, der Impfstoff war übrig, ne? So, irgendwie so, aha
der Impfstoff ist immer zufällig dann übrig, wenn was weiß ich, der Bischof von Mallorca, Karl-Heinz Rummenigge und irgendwelche Landräte und Bürgermeister in der Nähe stehen, ne? Und wenn irgendwie irgendeiner
da mal da mal ankommt, ne? Dann ist zufällig kein Impfstoff da, ne? Der ist immer nur übrig, wenn irgendwelche äh besonderen Figuren grade äh durchs Bild hinken. Und
und die Leute fressen das und sagen, ja Mensch, super, ne?
Der Bürgermeister, ja, auf Twitter hat mir jemand schön geantwortet, als ich mein meine Verwunderung darüber äh äußerte, ne, dass es immer nur dann ist, wenn da irgendwelche VIPs in der Nähe stehen. Sagt er, weil jemand, das ist Bürgernähe.
Fand ich ganz gut.
Nicht schlecht,
Aber es gibt äh tatsächlich so die, also es gibt so Situationen, äh habe ich gehört zum Beispiel bei ähm so Pflege äh Heim und so, dass
die ja dann auch so vor Ort äh verimpft werden, obwohl dann eben tatsächlich, weil's halt nicht aufgeht, ne, so einzelne.
Dosierung übrig sind, aber da wird es demnächst dann eine eine äh Änderung geben in der Reglementierung, dass das dann halt nicht mehr an irgendwelche Leute geimpft werden soll, sondern dann sollen sie's halt wegschmeißen.
Da gehe ich jetzt auch nicht so richtig mit.
Nein, das ist natürlich genauso Quatsch, aber es ist, es ist halt.
Schon auffällig, dass die nicht im Pflegeheim stehen und sagen, hä, wir haben Impfung über, lass mal einfach die Obdachlosen fragen, die bei uns vor der Tür zelten, sondern irgendwie plötzlich dann der, der Landrat ankommt oder irgendwelche anderen Vorbilder, ne?
Also sehr erstaunlich, sehr an Vorbildern, nicht arm.
Aber diese Bischöfe, das sind doch alles Seelsorger. Die sind doch im Prinzip auch im medizinischen Bereich unterwegs.
Nee, die haben sie doch umgemünzt äh auf die Altenpflege.
Wie umgemünzt.
Diese kirchlichen Vertreter, die haben sie, weil die ja weil die Kircheträgerin äh der Altenpflegeeinrichtung ist,
wurden dann da irgendwie die die Bischöfe und und Pfarrer die die haben alle kurzfristig sind die als Altenpfleger eingesprungen.
Ja, auch das Verwaltungspersonal, tja. Ich meine, auf der einen Seite, ich freue mich ja über jede Person
die wirklich sich auch impfen lassen möchte. Weil ich glaube, wir kommen jetzt auch so langsam in diese Situation, wo wir dann so das andere Problem kriegen, so dass du halt wirklich sagst, ja hier im Stoff, wer will oder so, ah nee
Ich will nicht gechipt werden.
Ich sage dir mal ganz ehrlich, äh ich habe da null
Humor und null Verständnis für. Ich habe ja in der äh vorletzten Sendung oder so schon erwähnt, dass ich mich für einen Freund von mir, um einen Impftermin in Nordrhein-Westfalen bemüht habe, erfolglos
Es handelt sich dabei um einen vierundachtzig Jahre alten Bergmann mit Staublunge, ja,
Ähm der, denke ich mal, so Risikogruppe relativ groß geschrieben da stehen hat. Und wir haben jetzt äh einen Impftermin,
eben sagen wir mal Mitte April. Ja und gleichzeitig höre ich hier irgendwelche Stories von Leuten, die,
In Impfzentren Probearbeiten gehen.
Bei der Gelegenheit die Impfung abgreifen und dann feststellen, dass das ja doch eine Arbeit ist, die ihren allgemeinen Ansprüchen nicht tauglich ist,
Ja? Weil die aber die erste Dosis bekommen haben, kriegen die dann natürlich auch noch die zweite, weil sonst wäre die erste Dosis ja verschenkt und vergeudet. Und diese Leute,
schämen sich noch nicht mal dafür, sondern die erzählen die Geschichte auch noch stolz im Freundes und Bekanntenkreis. Und da,
Ich habe für viel Humor. Ich habe für total viel Humor Tim. Du weißt, ich lache über alles. Aber über so eine solch über so wat fehlt mir der humoristische äh Draht zu.
Na, das ist natürlich auch ein extrem Beispiel, ne. Aber da daran mangelt es ja derzeit eigentlich auch nicht an extremen Beispielen für alles mögliche.
Naja, aber ich bin froh, dass ich bin froh, dass wir, ich mein, wir können eigentlich nur hoffen, dass die ganzen, äh, Impf
vordrängender Arschlöcher sich die die Fußballspiel des FC Bayern zum Vorbild nehmen und sagen, nee, komm, ey, solche Assiswitzer, so ein Assi willst du auch nicht sein? Insofern, vielleicht haben die ja tatsächlich eine Vorbildwirkung, dass das die Leute sagen, okay, komm,
Ich äh äh stelle mich hinten an und sorge dafür, dass diejenigen die Impfung bekommen, die sie brauchen.
Schön wär's. Aber Podcaster, ich bitte dich, also das ist auch eine seelsorgerische Tätigkeit, will ich ja machen.
Also würde ich, würde ich äh in den Genuss einer vorzeitigen Impfung kommen, ja? Oder würde mir eine vorzeige Impfung angeboten werden,
Selbstverständlich will ich sie sofort in Anspruch nehmen, aber ich hätte wenigstens den den Geschmack und das Feigefühl, das einfach niemandem zu erzählen. Kleiner Tipp.
Das wäre in der Tat äh ganz angemessen, ja.
So, dass das ist dann so, so kann man dann wenigstens aber sich dann noch irgendwie da in die Kreise setzen. Ich bin geimpft, Alter.
Weißt du, wenn während irgendwo noch die.
Lebensbedrohlich und und überhaupt, überhaupt was für eine privilegierte Situation, das ist überhaupt geimpft zu werden, wenn das mal im Vergleich zu Weltbevölkerung setzt, ne. Ist schon allein für Deutschland schon ein wahnsinniges Privileg.
Das auch noch zur Weltbevölkerung und dann sind das irgendwelche arbeitsscheuen Fatzkes, die irgendwie denen, die sich für die Arbeit am Impfzentrum zu schade waren, ne?
Ey. Und ich denke schon drüber nach. Ich habe tatsächlich überlegt, ob ich sage, okay, komm, dann arbeite ich jetzt in diesem Impfzentrum,
was ich da verdiene, ist mir eigentlich völlig egal, irgendwie bei einer, bei 'ner Jahrhundertaufgabe der Menschheit mitzuwirken ist 'ne große Ehre, ja?
Dein äh Enkelkindern von erzählen. Opa, was hast du damals gemacht? Ich habe,
in der Kälte gestanden und habe die Omas sortiert vom Impfzentrum. So das ist eine Heldentat, ja und ähm ähm da äh ob man da noch dafür geimpft wird oder nicht, wer sekundär aber ähm ähm,
natürlich zur Attraktivität des Anstellungsverhältnisses bei. Na ja, kommen wir zum Feedback-Tipp.
Ja, kommen wir zum Feedback.
Wir hatten in der letzten Sendung darüber diskutiert
was genau die Datenmenge ist, die bei einer SMS übertragen wird. Und äh glücklicherweise wurde das, also wir wir
schwenken da hin und her, zwischen irgendwie hundertvierzig Bite oder hundertsechzig Zeichen und wie das da genau ist, Pascal hat es nochmal erklärt, die maximale Länge einer SMS,
eintausendeinhundertzwanzig Bit. Und weil Aski sieben bitcodiert, sind es dann eben einhundertsechzig Zeichen.
Aber,
einhundertvierzig Bite, also hatten wir beide recht, mit der Erinnerung hundertvierzig hundertsechzig, bin ich immer wieder froh, wenn sowas ganz kurz und knackig erklärt wird.
Dann hatten wir die ähm,
Situation. Wir haben ja in der letzten Sendung mit Julia Reeder gesprochen und äh kurz nach dieser Sendung wurde dann so ein Fall bekannt, der ja ein bisschen ähm.
Eine Mischung aus äh ja wie war da die Reaktion? Also es geht da um ein äh um ein
Twitch-Streamer oder YouTube-Streamer oder was auch immer, der äh unter dem Handy Polizeieinsätze. Ah nee, auf Instagram. So und äh der filmt und streamt irgendwie Einsätze von
Polizisten, die den auch schon kennen.
Und dann einfach ähm Copyrighted Music anmachen äh in der Hoffnung, dass seine Aufzeichnung oder seinen Stream dann eben einem Upload-Filter zum Opfer fallen.
Wird. Das passiert nicht äh äh in diesem Fall, aber es ist natürlich ganz interessant, dass du jetzt hier schon siehst, äh,
Ja, ich fand das so ein bisschen, wir haben ja auch da in unserer Feedback äh Runde da nochmal drüber gesprochen, den Hack Value finde ich natürlich eigentlich ganz amüsant, aber es ist natürlich
nunmal so, dass Polizeibeamtinnen sich.
Bei ihrer Arbeit eben im Rahmen der Transparenz durchaus filmen lassen sollten und auch nichts dagegen haben sollten, ja? So äh ist die.
Situation.
Aber okay, also gibt es diesen Fall und äh wurde uns natürlich auch von mehreren ähm Hörerinnen,
berichtet und äh Julia hatte das dann glaube ich auch getwittert mit eben dem
Hinweis ja, zum Glück, ne, wenn während wir die ganze Zeit davor vor vor warnen, dass äh Upload-Filtern Zensur-Risiko haben, äh setzt die Polizei dieses Zensurrisiko halt auch schon um. Und das ist natürlich,
oder versucht die Polizei dieses äh Zensur Risiko umzusetzen.
Tja, dann gab es noch zu hatten wir letzte Woche verlesen, dass ähm.
Feedback von Chantal, die in der ähm,
In einer Behörde, in, jetzt, wie hieß nochmal das Bundesland Niedersachsen, genau, äh auf Lynux-Systemen seit vielen Jahren erfolgreich arbeitet und äh damit sehr zufrieden ist, dazu kommentierte dann.
Vier.
Zu dem Feedback von Chantal möchte ich anmerken, dass sich ihre Hoffnung darauf weiter unter Lenux arbeiten zu können, vermutlich nicht erfüllen wird. Die aktuelle Koalitionsvereinbarung zwischen CDU und SPD,
liefert dazu,
unten. Wir werden den in Niedersachsen bislangbasierten Verfahrensbetrieb aufgeben mit dem Ziel, auf diesem Weg, die länderübergreifende Zusammenarbeit zu erleichtern
und den Aufwand in Programmierung und Verfahrensbetreuung zu reduzieren,
dreitausendvierhundertdreiundfünfzig aus Koalitionsvertrag final und so weiter und noch ein heißer Artikel ist auch gleich dazu verlinkt.
Kommentiert vier weiter. Es sitzt also allein leider nichts, wenn Lenux erfolgreich eingesetzt wird. Leider kommen,
so das positiv gedachte Feedback von Chantal ein etwas traurigen, negativen Beigeschmack. Erstaunlich ist, dass die Migrationsinfo bei den Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeitern offensichtlich noch nicht einmal angekommen ist.
Ja
da antwortet Chantal natürlich sofort, na ja, angekommen, Info ist die Info natürlich schon bei mir über die Presse. Aber bisher gibt es keine Hinweise auf die Umsetzung und noch hoffe ich,
dass es sich wie so vieles im Sande verläuft. Ich glaube, mit der Hoffnung hat Chantal eventuell durchaus äh ja, also äh Aussicht,
Ja, ist ein IT-Großprojekt, äh das fällt in einer äh bei einer CDU relativ schnell auch mal hinten über. Ich muss natürlich auch anmerken, dass dieser Satz.
Äh Unsinn ist, ne, der, der da aus dem Koalitionsvertrag ist, weil wenn man sagt, ähm die zusammen, die länderübergreifende Zusammenarbeit zu erleichtern.
Ja das zahlst du ja dann klar, dann hast du dann machst du das auf Windows.
Dann hast du halt die teureren Kosten. Jetzt könntest du natürlich auch einfach sagen, die anderen Länder sollen mal auch,
äh den Weg der Zukunft des gehen, ne? Das könnte es genauso machen. Und dann sagen sie,
den Aufwand in Programmierung und Verfahrensbetreuung zu reduzieren. Da wird natürlich vergessen, dass du dann den Aufwand in äh Lizensierungen hast, ne? Äh was äh,
eben dauer, äh was was äh dauerhafte Kosten sind. Ewigkeitskosten während äh ja Programmierung und Optimierung eben einmalige Kosten sind. Und ja
Das ist ja die Falle. Klar, es ist so, die die äh die Initiale Investition ist höher
Aber genauso haben wir ja auch ähm andere Infrastruktur lieber entschieden, selber zu bauen. Statt sie dauerhaft von anderen zu mieten.
Zum Thema digitale Bildung hatten wir ja eine Sendung mit Steini. Die ist ja auch sehr gut angekommen und ähm da haben wir heute,
auf der Seite des CCC noch einmal die Forderungen von Chaos macht Schule veröffentlicht. Chaos macht Schule ist ja die Bildungs-, die ehrenamtliche Bildungsinitiative des Chaos Computerclubs.
Die sich erstens mit der digitalen Bildung generell auseinandersetzt, ähm,
und sich da ja inhaltlich positioniert und die aber vor allem zu Nicht-Corona-Zeiten, insbesondere gerne in die Schulklassen geht, um dort ja,
digitale digitale Basis Bürger,
Wissensangelegenheiten zu vermitteln, ja, also mal ein bisschen mehr zu erklären, was so in diesen sozialen Netzwerken funktioniert vorgeht, was Datenschutz bedeutet, digitale Bildung halt, ne? Und.
Steini, der bei uns zu Gast war, engagiert sich ja auch, äh unter anderem bei Chaos macht Schule. Und jetzt hat eben,
Das Team von Chaos macht Schule nochmal diese Positionen zusammengefasst, die Steine ja auch schon bei uns in der Sendung vermittelt hat. Unter dem äh Lockdown ohne Login.
Chaos macht Schule fordert, nachhaltige Lernplattformen, wo eben auch gesagt wird, okay, wir möchten erstens Rechtssicherheit für alle am Schulleben,
Beteiligten herstellen. Wir möchten diesen Login-Effekt vermeiden, der der eben auftritt, wenn man sich jetzt an die kommerziellen Anbieter bindet, stattdessen möchten wir in eine nachhaltige Lerninfrastruktur investieren, nach dem.
Konzept Public Money, Public Code, ne, was du einmal hier programmiert hast, kannst du dann eben quelloffen,
überall nutzen und es sollte eigentlich nahe liegen, wie sinnvoll das ist, als wenn man jetzt mal auf die Kosten.
Blickt hier eben nachhaltig zu arbeiten und mit den öffentlichen Geldern, öffentlichen Code zu produzieren, der dann wiederum allen Schulen in allen Bundesländern,
ähm äh zunutze,
wird. Entschuldigung, der Satz war unsinnig. Ähm das Ganze soll natürlich trotzdem dezentral bleiben und es gibt jetzt endlich die Praxiserprobten Lösungen und die müssen ausgebaut werden. Dabei wird jetzt gleichzeitig natürlich nicht unter den Teppich gekehrt, dass.
Deutschland eben insbesondere jetzt in dieser Lockdown-Situation von, ja, null auf hundert gehen musste oder sagen wir mal, von fünfzehn auf hundert gehen musste und das ist dabei natürlich zu Problemchen kam, auch dazu hatte,
sicher ausführlich geäußert.
Ja, das hat also noch äh eine weitere Positionierung der gesamten Initiative zur Folge gehabt und äh ja, schauen wir mal,
ob da auf uns gehört wird.
Ist auf jeden Fall ähm eine interessante Grundlage für eine neue Diskussion, wenn wir halt nach der nächsten Bundestagswahl eine neue Regierung bekommen und wenn so ich das sehe, hat ja auch die CDU mittlerweile die Forderung nach einem Digitalministerium in die äh auf ihre Fahnen geschrieben,
keine Ahnung, wie sie sich das jetzt äh konkret äh vorstellen, aber immerhin,
soll das sozusagen mal auf Ministerialebene gehoben werden, das Prinzip mit irgendwelchen Digitalverantwortlichen, die im Kanzleramt oder was weiß ich, wo einsortiert sind, das haben wir ja gesehen, das hat ja herzlich wenig gebracht
Und äh in dem Moment, wo man natürlich ein komplett neues Ministerium aufstellt, dann muss natürlich wirklich mal die Frage gestellt werden, was ist denn die digitale Strategie an sich? Haben wir oder
überhaupt erstmal gerne eine. Ja und dann ähm.
Anderen Aspekten, die wir schon diskutiert haben, Digitalvorbehalt et cetera voranzugehen, aber eben vor allem auch mal wirklich zu überlegen, was braucht,
Land für ein Betriebssystem. Ja, das wäre wäre wir reden ja davon, dass wir hier sicherlich auch eine Mischung haben werden immer aus,
privaten also Ressourcen, die durch private Unternehmen bereitgestellt werden, gar keine Frage, aber dass man eben.
Anstrebt. Das ist, glaube ich, der wichtige äh wichtige Wort in dem Zusammenhang, dass man anstrebt sozusagen eine offene Grundlage für,
wichtige Bereiche, sowohl für die Verwaltung, als eben auch für die Bildung zu schaffen.
Ja und da kommt natürlich immer dieser Begriff der digitalen Souveränität
der da fällt. Und da ist ja auch die Bundesregierung ganz heiß drauf, ne? Da wollen sie gerne haben, äh aber da kriegen sie natürlich nicht ohne, da auch selber in die äh dieser Souveränität irgendwie einen Nährboden zu bieten.
Thema Nährboden. Ähm wir haben es in den letzten Sendungen schon äh.
Am am Rande erwähnt. Ja, die Betreiberinfrastruktur.
Äh des Bot Netz Imoted wurde ja übernommen und wir haben dürfen jetzt noch gespannt sein, ob das nachhaltig,
gelungen ist oder nicht. Es gab da ein paar Verhaftungen und jetzt gab es eben eine, eine, ja, sehr, eine sehr vollmundige äh Siegesverkündung.
Die interessanterweise tatsächlich an dem Tag gemeldet wurde,
als das IT-Sicherheitsgesetz in erster Lesung im Deutschen Bundestag war, wo dann irgendwie, ne, Horst Seehofer nochmal schön sagen kann, hier Cyber Cyber. So und da fand sich in der äh in dieser Meldung,
dann eine relativ interessanter Satz. Durch die Übernahme der Kontrolle über die Infrastruktur.
War es möglich, die Schadsoftware auf betroffenen Deutschen? Opfersystem für die Täter unbrauchbar zu machen.
Um den Tätern jegliche Möglichkeit zu nehmen, die Kontrolle zurückzuerlangen.
Wurde die Schadsoftware auf den Opfersystemen in Quarantäne verschoben?
Und die Kommunikationsparameter der Schadsoftware so angepasst, dass die Opfersysteme ausschließlich.
Einer zu Beweissicherung eingerichteten Infrastruktur kommunizieren können. Aha.
Jetzt muss er sich mal überlegen, okay, was ist die Infrastruktur? Ja, die werden irgendeine Form von.
Command in Control Kommunikation haben, also E-Moted ist ja ein Trojaner so
und die werden irgendeine Form, der wird sich auf irgendeinem Weg verbindet, der sich zurück nach Hause. Und von dort wird er.
Dann Befehle erhalten, irgendwie Module nachladen oder sonstiges. Das ist E-Moted, das nachher auch eine rancreme ausgerollt wird, ist eben eher am Ende der Angriffskette. Dieser Satz klingt also,
ziemlich klar, dass man sagt, uns gehört diese Infrastruktur und das haben wir, die haben wir übernommen, ja, das werden sie also,
Auf welchem Weg auch immer einen administrativen Zugang zu haben und sagen, äh damit konnten wir jetzt auf diesem Weg, weil wir die Kontrolle der Infrastruktur haben, die Chartsoftware auf,
betroffenen deutschen Opfersystemen für die Täter unbrauchbar machen. Ähm mit anderen Worten, die haben irgendein Update für die Software gemacht.
Damit oder irgendeine Änderung an der Software vorgenommen, damit die Täter auch nicht wieder die Kontrolle zurückerlangen können.
Wie genau Sie das gemacht haben, ist unklar. Wenn man jetzt sagt, okay, es gibt diese eine Infrastruktur und wir haben die übernommen, dann könnte es ja theoretisch sein, dass die Täter eine zweite Infrastruktur bereitstellen, was du.
Zum Beispiel machst bei deiner ähm bei deiner Software ist, dass sie ähm pro Tag,
Also in Abhängigkeit des Tages ganz viele Domainnamen würfelt und nacheinander versucht, unter denen deine,
Kontrollinfrastruktur zu erreichen. Und du kannst aber einfach
zum Beispiel sagen, du musst nur eine dieser Domänen dann wirklich registrieren. Was eine relativ gute Möglichkeit ist, äh quasi eine dauerhafte Sperrung zu äh unterbinden. Nur so ein Gedanke.
Vor dem Hintergrund der nächste Satz, um den Tätern jegliche Möglichkeit zu nehmen, obwohl sie haben ja gerade gesagt, wir haben das den Tätern genommen, ne. Wir haben die Schadsoftware unbrauchbar gemacht. Haben sie gerade gesagt, im nächsten Satz sagen sie aber, um den Tätern jegliche Möglichkeit zu nehmen,
die Kontrolle zurückerlang, zu erlangen, wurde die Schadsoftware auf den Opfersystem in Quarantäne verschoben
okay und die Kommunikationsparameter der Schadsoftware so angepasst, dass die Opfersysteme ausschließlich mit einer zur Beweissicherung eingerichteten Infrastruktur kommunizieren können. Also sie haben eine.
Änderung an der,
Software auf an der Schadsoftware auf den Systemen der Opfer vorgenommen, die jetzt dazu führt, dass sie auf jeden Fall nur noch an eine eigens zu Beweissicherung eingerichtete Infrastruktur kommunizieren können,
So kommunizieren können ist interessant, weil also eigentlich schränkst du,
dass eine Software nur noch irgendwohin kommunizieren kann, durch ein weiteres, was weiß ich, Application Firewall System ein, ne? Aber hier geht es
offenbar um eine Änderung der Software. Es ist sehr nebulös und das jetzt in Technik zu übersetzen, klingt eben so ein bisschen, als okay, die haben die Infrastruktur übernommen und sie haben wahrscheinlich,
So klingt es darüber ein Update der Schadsoftware geschoben äh was wiederum die Schadsoftware gleich lässt aber nur die Kommunikation auf einen spezifischen Host konzentriert,
ja? Jetzt frage ich mich aber auch, weißt du, auf den Opfersystemen in Quarantäne verschoben, wo hast du hast du Quarantäne auf deinem Computer? Wo ist die denn?
Den Begriff wollte ich auch gerade noch hinterfragen. Also, was.
Ich weiß nicht ganz genau, wie ich das deuten soll, bin mir jetzt auch nicht sicher, ob ich irgendeinen Begriff aus der Security da nicht äh kenne, aber ich meine, in dem Moment, wo dieses Thema,
Quasi umzingelt sind, dann kannst du ihn ja ein beliebiges Internet äh vorgaukeln und damit den Zugriff von außen ja eigentlich auch komplett sperren.
Ja, ja, aber dafür müsstest du ja erstmal, aber das wäre ja ein massiver Eingriff in das System.
Noch live ist sozusagen.
Naja, es geht ja hier, es geht ja hier um äh also wenn ich das, wie gesagt, hier ist sehr viel Kaffeesatz diese Reihe, aber was ich hier eigentlich verstehe, ist die Reden jetzt hier von Systemen, die Emoted befallen sind,
das aber noch nicht wissen. Ne, also Evotec ist ja die Gang, die erst infiziert.
Dann Module nachlädt, das komplette Netzwerk infiltriert und dann potenziell zur Tat schreitet und verschlüsselt.
Jetzt kann das aber natürlich auch sein, dass die einmal kurz bei dir reinschauen und sagen, alles klar, hier ist nichts in unserer Kragenweite zu holen,
und lassen dich einfach ja verschwenden keine weitere Zeit auf dich, ne? Hör mal für Privatpersonen scheint Emoted ein geringeres Risiko zu sein,
eben lieber dort ihre Zeit investieren, wo sie potentielle Unternehmen mit entsprechenden Einkünften an der Angel haben. Ähm.
Oder sie finden irgendwelche Word-Dokumente, die auf russisch sind.
Ne, das kann ja alles, also so jetzt ist nur die Frage, ähm.
Wie schiebst du jetzt, also wenn du jetzt die wenn du die Kommandeten-Control-Infrastruktur hast.
Wenn du jetzt sagst, okay, die wir passen die Schadsoftware an, ja okay, dann konfigurieren wir die oben oder so und schneiden die dauerhaft an ab, aber dann sagen sie, wir schieben die jetzt außerdem noch in Quarantäne. Also ehrlich gesagt glaube ich, was sie damit meinen, äh,
ja auch bei Windows.
Irgendwie diese wahrscheinlich so diese Datei, wo dass du Dateien flext, die nicht sofort ausgeführt werden können, weißt du?
Also macOS macht das inzwischen und sagt, diese Datei wurde aus dem Internet heruntergeladen und ich
glaube, dass äh äh Windows auch so ein ähnliches Filetsystem Fleck hat. Ich hatte zumindest zuletzt ein Projekt, wo ich
Schadsoftware für Windows bauen musste und das hat mir wirklich ein bisschen Kopfschmerzen gemacht. Das ist gar nicht so einfach. Muss ich ehrlich sagen. Da dieser Windows Defender.
Ist er durchaus aktiv. Aber was heißt das jetzt, wenn du eine.
Was ist jetzt zum Beispiel, wenn die Systeme diese äh diese Funktionalitäten nicht aktiviert haben? Also das ist alles relativ komisch. Und wir werden das jetzt auch nicht aufklären. Die interessante Frage ist nämlich jetzt.
Auf welcher Rechtsgrundlage hat das BKA denn diese Maßnahmen durchgeführt? Weil die sagen ja sogar spezifisch, wir haben das für Deutsche gemacht. Ist jetzt interessant, weil es heißen könnte, für andere habt ihr's nicht gemacht oder was, ne?
Dann wurde mal angefragt, ich glaube Anapisselli hat das gemacht von,
Netzpolitik Org und äh da wurde ihr von dem äh Sprecher des ZIT,
geantwortet, die Zentralstelle Internetkriminalität oder sowas. Die konkreten Bestimmungen der Strafprozessordnung und damit derer deren genauer Wortlaut,
auf deren Grundlage die richterlichen Beschlüsse ergangen sind, kann ich ihnen zum derzeitigen Zeitpunkt nicht nennen, um die weiterhin andauernden international abgestimmten Ermittlungen nicht zu gefährden
Das ist geil. Wir wir können ihnen nicht sagen, was in unseren Gesetzen steht und was Richter auf Basis dieser Gesetze äh beschlossen haben.
Weil das könnte international abgestimmte Ermittlungen gefährden. Das finde ich ein bisschen äh.
Finde ich ein bisschen überraschend, ja. Äh gleichzeitig.
Ist das ja insgesamt, ne, das das riecht alles so ein bisschen nach Hackback. Und da muss ich jetzt ja auch mal sagen, so, bei allem, bei aller Hackback Kritik, ähm.
Dieses, also das, was hier passiert, ist, wenn es so stimmt.
Wie es dort äh beschrieben wird, wäre ja mal einer der seltenen Fälle von.
Hack back hat was gebracht,
Also die haben irgendwie diese Infrastruktur übernommen und konnten jetzt potenziell weiteren Schaden abwenden. Jetzt stellt sich die Frage primär haben sie einen weiteren Schaden hoffentlich dadurch abgewendet, dass sie alle Drahtzieher ähm.
Verhaftet haben, aber sie haben offenbar weiterhin auch Möglichkeiten für notwendig befunden, um eine.
Potentielle Reaktivierung zu verhindern, ne? Und das wäre jetzt also in diesem einen konkreten Fall.
Durchaus keine.
Nichts Schlechtes. Trotzdem müssen aber natürlich findige Journalistin, wie in diesem Fall, die Anna, fragen,
auf welcher rechtlichen Basis ist das denn passiert? Denn gleichzeitig wird ja in dem ähm.
In dem äh IT-Sicherheitsgesetz zwei Punkt null gefordert,
dass das eine solche Möglichkeiten überhaupt erstmal gegeben werden. Also in dem,
zweiten IT-Sicherheitsgesetz soll die gesetzliche Grundlage dafür geschaffen werden, dass staatliche Stellen solche Eingriffe in infizierte Systeme anordnen können, damit die bereinigt werden können. Das heißt, vermutlich.
Zumindest laut der Autorinnen des zweiten IT-Sicherheitsgesetzes fehlt die rechtliche Grundlage für das, was hier jetzt grade passiert,
Und wenn die rechtliche Grundlage für das, was jetzt gerade passiert, ist nicht fehlt, dann stellt sich die Frage, warum muss das denn im IT-Sicherheitsgesetz äh neue Befugnisse geben?
Also irgendwie ist das äh verdächtig, ja. Und ich sage nochmal, also äh ich hatte das ja, glaube ich, auch erwähnt. Ich habe das nicht nur einmal hinter äh Angriffen aufgeräumt.
Und äh.
Kann sagen, die willst du echt, die Infektion willst du echt nicht haben und wenn dir der Staat die äh noch kostenlos von deinem Rechner putzt, obwohl du die schon im Netz hast, dann ist das wahrscheinlich etwas sehr gutes.
Und aber trotzdem müssen die natürlich für jedes Handeln eine Rechtsgrundlage haben,
und wenn sie die nicht haben, ist das nun mal leider nicht ohne weiteres zu rechtfertigen, was sie da getan haben. Und äh Anna hat dann auch noch ein bisschen äh andere.
Juristinnen und so gefragt, die.
Dass eben auch äh unterschiedlich bewerten, in auf welcher Rechtsgrundlage die Polizei das denn getan haben will. Kann natürlich sehr gut sein.
Dass sie das Hütchen aus dem äh.
Dass sie irgendwie noch so aus dem Hut ziehen, dass das eigentlich dann die Amerikaner für sie gemacht haben oder so, ne? Und das irgendwie versuchen nochmal in den, in den Juristiken zu waschen
Allerdings erkenne ich jetzt mal an, das wäre jetzt mal ein Fall von Hackback im weitesten Sinne oder von Übernahme von Angreifer, Infrastruktur und dann darüber Ausführen von Handlungen, die die.
Bevölkerung schützen.
Im weitesten Sinne der letzte mir bekannte Fall, wo so etwas sich mal ergeben hat, ist viele Jahre her, ja. Also das ist wirklich nichts, was an der Tagesordnung ist.
Und könnte eben potentiell interessant sein. Es ist weiterhin angekündigt, ja, dass sie ähm eine massenhafte äh Deinstallation planen,
Und am fünfundzwanzigsten April.
Alle mit Emoje, bei allen mit EMOTED infizierten Geräten eine Desinfektion.
Oder eine Deinstallation vornehmen wollen, was auch spannend ist.
Vielleicht äh vielleicht hat die, vielleicht gibt's ja schon irgendeine Verordnung, die uns nicht bekannt ist, so eine Art digitaler digitales Infektionsschutz äh Gesetz, wo einfach Infektion ist jetzt verboten und jetzt kommt das BKA und impft die Computer.
Damit das nicht weiter passieren kann.
Also ich meine wahrscheinlich, wenn sie wirklich sagen, sie haben jetzt eine, die ähm sie haben jetzt die.
Infrastruktur, dann können sie im Zweifelsfall natürlich auch sagen, okay, äh wir geben jetzt dir eine Deinstallationsroutine und es gibt Hinweise darauf, dass sie diese deinstallation quasi mit einer eigenen Software machen.
Und die da gibt es schon irgendwelche Verdachtsmomente, dass irgendwie auf Virus Toiled bestimmte Software gefunden wurde, die im Prinzip ein mit Deinstallation ist oder sowas, aber das war mir noch ein bisschen zu viel.
Kaffeesatzleserei.
Hat keine eigene äh Löschdichtfunktion.
Ähm im also im dafür kenne ich's nicht gut genug, aber im Zweifelsfall wirst du es irgendwie dazu kriegen, sich selber zu zerstören
Also du kannst ja über Evotec Module nachladen, kannst damit sehr viel machen und damit kannst du natürlich auch den Befehl abgeben, was weiß ich, löscht die Radgestry-Einträge oder die, der Weg, wie du ausgeführt wirst und lösch dich selber, ne?
Ist am Ende schon ein einfacher Trojaner und mit einem einfachen Trojaner, den kannst du auch immer die Rechte, die du immer damit hast, auf dem einen oder den anderen Weg,
nutzen, um dich um den um dich selber zu entfernen. Ne, das wird auf jeden Fall gehen.
Also ich will damit sagen, auch ohne eine spezifische ähm.
Deinstallier dich Funktion, weil du eigentlich immer irgendeine hier Basic Schal für mein Powershall Kommando aus oder so. Damit kannst du dich ja dann deinstallieren.
Das heißt, das ist wahrscheinlich das, was sie gemacht haben. Das sieht also eine digitale T-Zelle reinschicken und damit das Imbo-Tex äh aufgefressen wird.
Ich du, das ist das ist das, was mich so, was mich daran so ärgert, ist halt so, jetzt fragst dich, warum am fünfundzwanzigsten April? Warum nicht am äh ne, also warum, äh das ist ja noch lange hin. Jetzt ist ja gerade mal der fünfzehnte Februar.
Vielleicht haben sie einfach die Impfstofflieferung noch nicht bekommen.
Ne, also es kann gut sein, sodass sie sagen, okay, wir möchten.
Hundertprozentig sicher sein, dass wir keinen Schaden anrichten und äh wir testen das jetzt äh in
der Reihe nach, ne und müssen sicher gehen, dass diese Infektionen auch wirklich ohne Schaden und ohne Fehler passieren und deswegen suchen wir noch ein bisschen, ne. Also
das würde schon alles irgendwie Sinn machen, aber es auch andererseits komisch, das halt jetzt schon anzukündigen. Also das ist alles so.
Meldungen machen irgendwie.
Nicht so wirklich Sinn. Und es gibt auf jeden Fall Leute, die ja, also es gibt hier mehrere Forscherin, die sagen, es gibt einen,
E-Boot also die Deinstallation ist jetzt eher ein.
Also ein eigenes Programm und du kannst wahrscheinlich dann über EvoTED einfach sagen, okay, lade das mal runter und führ's aus, ne? Das ist ja so mit dass das Einfachste, was du tun kannst. Und hier äh also ich sehe da mehrere,
ähm mehrere ähm Tweets zu von äh ja.
Forschern, die das äh sagen wir mal,
ernsthaft betreiben, die jetzt irgendwie eine auf Virus Toile eine Schadsoftware untersuchen, die offensichtlich oder offenbar äh als äh als Ziel hat.
Eine ein Deinstallation vorzunehmen.
Willst du nochmal kurz sagen, was Tote ist?
Virus Ton ist eine ziemlich coole Plattform, die ich glaube, irgendwie auch leider an Google inzwischen dranhängt, ursprünglich aber mal noch nicht da war. Das ist einfach eine riesige ähm.
Äh also sagen wir mal so, du du lädst deine Datei rein.
Und die wird dann mit allen verfügbaren Virenscanner oder mit sehr vielen verfügbaren Virenscannern gescannt
Und das Ergebnis dir jeweils gesagt. Also durch den Upload einer Datei auf Virus Todal kannst du die mit was weiß ich, siebzig oder was äh Viren scannern,
scannen lassen und kriegst das Ergebnis angezeigt. Ähm,
Das Ding hat aber natürlich noch für Forscherinnen äh sehr interessante weitere Funktionalitäten, dass sie zum Beispiel nämlich die History angezeigt wird. Wann wurde das Bier hergestellt? Wann wurde es dort hochgeladen und so weiter.
Ja? Und ähm.
Du wir haben das zum Beispiel auch als Thorsten und ich hier diese ganzen bei Trojaner ähm analysiert haben, war der,
first submissional, natürlich auch einer der Beweise, die wir für den Zeitpunkt, wann diese Dateien jeweils existiert haben.
Mhm, hm.
Gezogen haben. Dadurch haben wir auch die,
Versionen von im Wandel, quasi zeitlich sortiert, dass wir einfach gesagt haben, na ja okay, grob können wir erstmal davon ausgehen.
Dass die ungefähr in der Reihenfolge hergestellt wurden, wie sie auch,
als allererstes auf Virus Toröl hochgeladen wurden. Ne? Nicht nicht einhundert Prozent, aber wenn etwas, ne, wenn eine Datei vor der anderen hochgeladen wurde, ist das ein gutes Indizes, die auch älter ist.
Aber das ist nur so eine, das ist jetzt nur so eine eine Datenbank, der man allgemein vertraut. Die haben da jetzt nicht noch so Blockchainfood oder so.
Nee, die haben, was die haben, ist, äh, für vertrauenswürdige, äh, IT-Security-Forscher, auch tatsächlich Zugriff auf die Datei, die da hochgeladen werden. Also, 'ne total schlechte Idee ist, wenn man selber grade mal Schadsoftware bastelt,
reinzuwerfen, weil das halt sehr gut sein kann, dass vielleicht die Virenscanner nicht anschlagen, gegen die du checkst.
Aber äh hintenrum halt schon mal irgendwelche äh Schadsoftware-Forscher äh dein dein deine Fortschritte,
bei der Schadsoftware-Programmierung beobachten oder äh,
irgendwelche Dateien da hochzuladen, wo vielleicht doch Personen bezogene Daten drin sind, äh ist halt nicht so eine schlechte, nicht so eine gute Idee, ne, weil du kannst da alles hochladen, aber ja, da haben halt auch Leute,
Zugriff drauf. Und das ist so ein bisschen auch der Punkt, wie warum so cool ist oder warum das halt so spannend ist, weil es eine Community dahinter gibt, die dann eben unterschiedliche,
äh Inputs noch dazugeben kann und darüber diskutiert oder hier zum Beispiel zu dieser.
Irgendwie die Evotec Confix oder in dem Fall von die mal noch mit dazu schreiben und dann halt bei spannender Schadsoftware siehst du es halt,
dass Leute äh sich da auch drauf werfen, dass es jetzt hier bei diesem
durchaus auch der Fall, dass da eben Leute sagen, guck mal hier, hier ist unser Report, wir haben die mal in einer VM Ausführung lassen und so. Also, wenn du nicht wenn du dich für Schadsoftware interessierst, oder
potenziellen Fall hast, äh kommst du eigentlich nicht um äh herum.
Ist so die Plattform für schadsoftware Analyse. Aber, wie gesagt, vorsichtig sein, was man da reinwirft, äh das.
Wird dann eben auch analysiert. Also man sollte da im Zweifelsfall nur was reinwerfen, von dem man möchte, dass es sich angeschaut wird.
Ja, also, aber um nochmal zum, zum Fazit zu kommen,
Es ist nicht ganz klar, immer noch nicht ganz klar, was das BKA da gemacht hat. Es klingt nach etwas, was potenziell in diesem konkreten Fall durchaus äh angemessen,
und.
Lobenswert wäre, ja? Es klingt aber auch nach etwas, wo man nicht weiß, ob die die Rechtsgrundlage haben und sie geben die Rechtsgrundlage auch nicht an. Und da muss man dann vielleicht potenziell echt sagen, dass,
Insgesamt das vielleicht eher eine Aufgabe wäre, die man vielleicht beim BSI sehen würde, ne. Ähm
bevor man jetzt irgendwie das BKA hier rumrennen hat und sagt, jo, geil, wir übernehmen mal alles und schalten das ab und hier die die Software löschen wir auch mal von deinem Computer, Linus, äh du wirst es uns später danken.
Also das ist juristisch gerade sehr komisch und das will man natürlich eigentlich nicht.
Ja, stimmt. Es ist eigentlich mehr eine Aufgabe fürs BSI, ne?
Zumal eben dann sich die Frage stellt, wenn die das jetzt eh gerade schon können, warum werden wir dann mit diesem IT-Sicherheitsgesetz zwei null,
belästigt, wo dafür eine Rechtsgrundlage geschaffen werden soll. Also da, was stimmt da nicht? Und das ist unabhängig davon, dass ich jetzt sage, A,
wahrscheinlich, also wahrscheinlich ist es sinnvoll diese Infektionen zu entfernen und was ich auch noch überhaupt nicht verstanden habe, ist warum das erst am fünfundzwanzigsten April äh passieren soll.
Aber ja, werden wir hoffentlich noch einiges drüber lernen.
Gut, kommen wir zur Welt der Informationsanfragen und Auskünfte.
Ja
Unsere Freunde von frag den Staat. Das ist wir wollten immer mit denen schon über Frontex reden und haben das ein bisschen verbaselt. Jetzt haben sie's äh auf auf anderem Wege geschafft.
Das die ganze, ganz Deutschland oder ganz Europa über Frontex redet. Sie haben ja schon relativ viele
Information, also Informationsfreiheitsanfragen an Frontex gesendet.
Und äh einigen von denen wurde stattgegeben, anderen nicht. Sie hatten den zum Beispiel mal die gefragt, okay ähm.
Welche äh Boote sie zum Migrationsabwehr im Mittelmeer einsetzen.
Wollten spezifisch die Namen der Fischer äh der,
der Schiffe haben, um dann eben besser kontrollieren zu können, ob die die sogenannten Push-Backs, also die Illegalen Zurückschiebungen vornehmen. Dafür gibt es ja ähm,
ausreichend dramatisches Beweismaterial, dass solche Fälle eben zeigt, wo die,
Menschen, die jetzt ins auf diesen Booten sich da im Mittelmeer befinden und in Seenot geraten sind, mit ihren
Schiffen quasi durch Wellengang versuchen zur Umkehr zu drängen und in einem Fall auch quasi dieses Boot nehmen und ähm,
zurückschieben in anderes libysches Gewässer, um sie so an der
Flucht nach Europa zu hindern und das ist natürlich nicht nur unappetitlich, sondern auch
absolut illegal, weil sie ja hier Menschen, die in Seenot sind, die Hilfe verweigern und die in ein äh ne, also quasi an der Landesgrenze zurückweisen, obwohl die ja bekanntermaßen Asylberechtigt sind. Ähm,
Deswegen hat Frontex ja ohnehin schon Ärger, ja?
Jetzt haben sie also mit dieser Anfrage nach den allgemeinen Missionen im Mittelmeer, wo es dann eben auch, wenn ich das richtig verstehe, äh um die äh,
Namen von den Booten gingen insgesamt zu wissen, ey, was macht ihr denn da eigentlich so, ne? Erklärt mal ein bisschen und darauf, das hat Frontex dann damals äh quasi,
abgelehnt, diese Informationsfreiheitsanfrage zu entsprechen und dann wurde, mussten sie klagen und dann haben sie am Ende verloren.
Ja, also ihre Informationsfreiheitsanfrage wurde tatsächlich nicht stattgegeben und dann hat Frontex.
Frag den Staat auf Erstattung der Anwaltskosten verklagt.
Haben gesagt, hier, ne, ihr habt diese Informationsfreiheit-Anfragen gestellt, ihr habt uns verklagt. Wir hatten Anwaltskosten, die müsst ihr uns jetzt äh starten.
Kann man sich jetzt drüber streiten, werden die eben auch vor Gericht klären, weil sich natürlich die Frage stellt, muss jetzt äh muss jetzt.
Frag den Staat, dafür zahlen, dass sie versucht haben, einen Rechtsanspruch durchzusetzen, den sie nicht hatten, ne? Aber sagen wir mal so, fragt den Staat, zankt sich seit längerer Zeit mit Frontex. Und jetzt.
Hat frag die Stadt, aber die Dokumente, die sie bekommen haben, natürlich auch genau angeschaut und jetzt eben vor kurzem die Frontex-Files veröffentlicht, ähm die,
Eine Reihe von Dokumenten sind, die sie eben von Frontex bekommen haben und sich genau angeschaut haben, da geht's über,
um Workshops und Industriedays, wo sich Frontex mit,
einer Reihe von Wirtschaftsvertreterinnen äh zum Informationsaustausch getroffen hat.
Über maritime Analysewerkzeuge und den äh,
biometrische Lösungen und so weiter, also eine ganze Reihe der gesamten,
ja so Militär und Migrationskontrolletechnologien und sie wurden aber zwanzig achtzehn von einem EU-Parlamentsabgeordneten gefragt,
ob's wie sie denn so an Treffen mit Lobbyisten teilgenommen haben
ja? Und da haben hat Frontex immer angegeben, sie würden sich nur mit Personen treffen, die im EU Transparenzregister.
Registriert sind. Und in diesen Unterlagen zeigt sich aber nun, dass sie relativ viele treffen mit unterschiedlichen Lobbygruppen gegeben haben,
von denen äh insgesamt mehr als die Hälfte nicht bei der EU registriert war. Also haben sie auf diese parlamentarische Anfrage äh nicht,
der Wahrheit geantwortet und äh wie wenn man sich hier anschaut, das sind eben einfach nur so Firmen.
Präsentation, das ist schon, würde ich jetzt sagen, etwas, wo man schon erwarten würde, dass das
direkte Arbeit von Frontex betrifft und wenn die sich damit Wirtschaftsvertretern treffen. Und da genau nachgefragt wird, dass das dann durchaus eine Rolle spielen könnte
jetzt haben wir also neben dem offiziellen Ermittlungsverfahren auf EU-Ebene.
Ähm wegen der illegalen Push-Backs noch das Problem, dass es hier mit der.
Lobbyintransparenz, auch nicht so ernst genommen wird. Das Ganze wurde relativ medienwirksam mit äh also mithilfe von Jan Böhmermann.
Veröffentlicht, der hier eben das Release der Frontex Files in der ZDF, im ZDF-Magazin Royal auch nochmal behandelt hat, das Video, wenn ihr's noch nicht gesehen habt, findet ihr im Falls in den.
Immer wieder spannend, was unsere lieben Freude von Frag den Staat so an äh.
Also da da scheißen sich doch die Leute bestimmt schon mittlerweile total in die Hose, wenn die irgendwie am Horizont auftauchen, oder?
Also ich ich glaube, dass natürlich auch vor dem Hintergrund solche Entscheidungen getroffen werden, wie zu sagen, wir wir klagen ähm.
Wir klagen vierundzwanzigtausend Euro aus denen raus. Die waren ja.
Wenn ich mich nicht täusche, ne, haben die hier diese Treffen. Da gab's ja allein Menüs im Wert von fast sechsstelligen Beträgen, ja, äh die dann da, äh fürs Abendessen, so ungefähr ausgegeben werden. Insofern
klar versuchen, wenn die eine kleine NGO wie frag den Staat um fünfundzwanzigtausend Euro Anwaltskosten
verklagen, äh dann geht es dabei nicht unbedingt darum, dass den jetzt die fünfundzwanzigtausend Euro in ihrem Millionenbudget fehlen, sondern darum,
zu sagen, ey.
Einzuschüchtern.
Scheiß. So, ne? Das ist ja, da geht's um Einschüchterung, ja.
Ja, insofern äh haben sie ja gesehen, was sie jetzt davon haben. Jetzt haben sie direkt noch mehr Aufmerksamkeit auf ihrem Treiben und den nächsten.
Potenzialen äh Skandal der untersucht werden muss, weil naja, wenn die, also wenn ihnen Parlamentariern eine falsche Auskunft geben, das macht halt keinen, macht halt keinen guten Eindruck, ne.
Ja.
Ihr macht einfach keinen guten Eindruck.
Punkt EU. Da ist das alles schön auf bearbeitet zum nachklicken.
Finde ich, finde ich ganz schön. Also insgesamt auch diese Zusammenarbeit, die dann da stattgefunden hat, ne, mit mit Bümmermann äh gemeinsam zu veröffentlichen und so, dass äh macht doch einen ganz guten Eindruck.
Ja, mal gucken, wie wie weit das noch hochkocht. Ich meine, es ist es ist schon ein bisschen,
krass. Man hat schon so den Eindruck, dass dass es auch so kollektiv etwas ist, was so von der Bevölkerung auch nicht wahrgenommen werden möchte.
Ja, du Migrationsabwehr, wie die das betreiben.
Ist halt so eine unappetitliche Sache, ne.
Wenn wenn du wenn die Gesellschaft irgendwie schon zu weiten Teilen so was sagt wie ja aber das Boot ist ja auch voll, das können ja nicht alle kommen so, ne? Und
wissen ja auch und die Schlepper von Seawatch und so, ne? Da will halt dann keiner hingucken,
was das eben auch bedeutet, wenn du da, wenn du dir da so eine, so eine Polizeiagentur heranziehst
züchtest, die diese Arbeit für dich macht, die aufpasst, dass hier bei dir nicht mal gegenüber ein halbes Jahr oder auch zwei Jahre lang ein paar Geflüchtete leben, bis sie Gelegenheit hatten, sich hier
vollständig zu integrieren. Und wenn du das, wenn du denen diese Gelegenheiten verwehrst und die hier ne,
mit wenig Möglichkeiten am Langarm verdorren lässt und det besser findest, ich denke ja auch, man muss ja ganz einfach sagen, es gibt wahrscheinlich viele Menschen.
Die, wenn sie hören.
Ja, das finde ich doch eigentlich ganz gut, wenn da auf dem Mittelmeer die potenziellen äh Asylbewerber zurückgedrängt werden, ne? Das findet man halt auch nur so lange gut, bis man halt mal ein Video davon sieht, wie das aussieht.
Menschen in der Gummifluppe vom Militärboot zurückgedrängt werden. Und in Seenot ausgesetzt werden.
Und potenziell das Risiko haben, äh dann zu ertrinken. Das ist halt schon wichtig, denke ich für die politische äh Meinungsbildung und Aufklärung in dem Bereich, sich soweit auch mal anzugucken.
Was das, was das bedeutet, wie gesagt, das ist relativ unappetitlich. Und wenn man sich die äh wenn man sich mal anschaut, was Sea-Watch für Videos liefert von solchen Rettungseinsätzen.
Oder auch mal, wenn sie zu spät kommen.
Das muss man sich dann schon mal angucken. Wenn man sich da seine vollständige äh Meinung äh drüberbilden möchte, im im warmen Zimmerchen bei minus zwanzig Grad draußen und irgendwie einen erzählt von äh äh.
Boot ist voll oder sonst was.
Ja, Frontex baut da eine Mauer und fragt den Staat soll dafür bezahlen.
Ja
Nö, äh tatsächlich bezahlt ja die Europäische Union äh relativ gut dafür, ne? Also, dass äh die die Frontex kriegt da äh regelmäßig seine ähm Erhöhungen im im Budget,
Und ja, aber fragt den Staat, soll da jetzt also auch noch seinen seinen Beitrag zu leisten?
Die Schnittchen zumindest die Schnittchen bezahlt für die Lobbyisten.
Dafür können die also für das Geld, was sie von frag den Staat verlangen, werden sie äh nicht allzu viele Schnittchen bekommen für ihre opulenten Essen da.
Ach ja.
Das ist natürlich auch also wenn du dir mal guckst, was da für Unternehmen sind, ne. Das ist dein, das sind natürlich alles so äh Militärunternehmen.
Militär und Polizei äh Systeme,
die da äh ich meine, wie gesagt, das geht hier nicht, das sind keine Hippies, das geht hier um konkrete äh Überwachungssysteme, Kampfsysteme.
Drohnen.
Ne? Drohnen haben den Vorteil, mit Drohnen kannst du äh musst du äh Seenot äh in Sonde geraten, der nicht aufnehmen.
Mit einer Drohne rum und guckst, wo die sind, weil wenn du mit einem Boot da bist und und,
guckt einer zu, dann äh bist du nachher wegen unterlassener Hilfeleistung oder oder illegaler Push-Backs dran, wenn du es schaffst, sie mit der Drohne irgendwie zu zu nerven oder früh genug der sogenannten äh libyschen Küstenwache Bescheid zu geben.
Die ja den also der Name erweckt ja den Eindruck, das wäre eine eine äh Küstenwache
irgendwie die Menschen rettet oder so, aber ist natürlich eigentlich sind das Schergen, die versuchen, die Menschen da zu behalten, die aus gutem Grund fliehen und die dann zu foltern, wenn sie die bei der Flucht erwischt haben.
Ja, das ist alles eine relativ unappetitliches Thema. Und da müssen wir dann eben leider als Bürgerinnen und Bürger dieser Demokratie auch hinschauen und gucken äh und uns darüber eine Meinung bilden, ob wir das so richtig finden oder nicht.
Auberginus, das sind doch alles europäische Rüstungsunternehmen. Das sind doch Arbeitsplätze, die da äh erhalten werden. Da wird moderne Technologie zur Anwendung gebracht. Es sichert auch unsere Zukunft.
Ja, zum Beispiel äh äh Heckler und Kochsign Sauerglock und Glock und Grand Power. Grand Power ist wohl auch ein äh Handfeuerwaffenhersteller.
Äh die wurden äh da eingeladen, sollten wir bitte ihre neun Millimeter klaren zeigen und äh sich für eine Ausschreibung äh bereitzuhalten, weil die eintausendeinhundert Kompaktpistolen Kaliber neun Millimeter suchen.
So, das ist äh Frontex, das ist die Migrationsabwehr, eintausendeinhundert Knarren broste.
Und ein paar Boote und ein paar Drohnen. Also ja, das ist das schafft auch alles Arbeitsplätze. Das kannst du wohl so sagen.
Gut, kommen wir zu den nächsten Klagen, Klageliedern, die angestimmt werden.
Richtig, Klagelieder, wir wir bleiben nochmal in der äh sogenannten
Migrationskontrolle. Äh und zwar ist es ja seit, ich glaube, zwanzig siebzehn äh mit gesetzlicher Grund, da halbwegs gängige Praxis.
Dass bei bei dass das Bundesamt für Migration und Flüchtlinge.
Smartphones von Geflüchteten ausliest. Ja und die Idee dahinter ist ja, ja gib Handy, ne und dann äh kontrollieren wir das, ob du,
ob dieses Handy Hinweise über deinen vorheriges Leben enthält, die dir irgendwie es ermöglichen, uns glaubhaft zu machen, dass du aus einem zur fluchtberechtigten,
Region kommst.
Und da haben sie äh im ersten Halbjahr zwanzig zwanzig, zweitausenddreihundertfünfunddreißig Datenträger ausgelesen und.
Davon sind sechshundertsechsundfünfzig Auswertungen entstanden, die tatsächlich von den Entscheiderinnen auch zu Rate gezogen wurden.
Die meisten davon waren nicht brauchbar, also in achtundsechzig Prozent der Fälle gab es keine verwertbaren Ergebnisse. In dreißig Prozent,
haben, die dann die Ergebnisse, die Angaben der schutzsuchenden bestätigt. Ja, also zweitausenddreihundertfünfunddreißig Datenträger,
sechshundertsechsundfünfzig tatsächliche Auswertungen und von den sechshundertsechsundfünfzig waren zwei Drittel keine verwertbaren Ergebnisse, ein Drittel,
hat die Angaben bestätigt und in zwei Prozent der Fälle hätte jetzt irgendwie die.
Die Angaben der Antragstellerinnen anhand dieser Datenanalyse widerlegt werden können. Das sind dann neun Antragstellerinnen von,
zweitausenddreihundertfünfunddreißig beziehungsweise sechshundertsechsundfünfzig, wo tatsächlich eine äh Auswertung vorgenommen wurde.
Und die Gesellschaft für Freiheitsrechte, also die GF,
klagt mit drei Geflüchteten gegen dieses Verfahren. Wir haben da hier auch schon öfter mal drüber gesprochen und ich habe auch mit der Lea Beckmann übrigens in Logbuch Freiheit unserem,
YouTube-Kanälen da mal drüber gesprochen, die natürlich auch sagt, ja
jemand, der sich gegen so etwas wehrt, zu finden, ist gar nicht so einfach, weil die meisten Leute haben ja eben auch diese Verfahren da gerade am Laufen. Das erfordert natürlich aber auch Mut, sich diesem,
potenziellen Rechtsmissbrauch dann eben entgegenzustellen. Und das äh.
Habe aber jetzt hier Leute getan. Lea Beckmann, wie gesagt, betreut dieses Ding bei der KFF und die haben sich jetzt außerdem noch an mit einer Beschwerde an den Bundesdatenschutzbeauftragten,
Ulrich Kälber gewendet. So und warum haben sie das jetzt gemacht?
Nun, dieses Verfahren ist da eben seit mehr oder weniger einem Jahr anhängig, da passiert nichts großartig und
der BFDI kann jetzt eben diesen Vorgang prüfen, vom äh BAMF Informationen verlangen und wenn der jetzt ein Verstoß gegen die deutsche Rechtsgrundlage,
feststellen würde, dann könnte er eben dieser Praxis auch schon vorher ähm.
Einhalt gebieten. Ja, das ist also die Hoffnung dieser Beschwerde, weil sie eben davon ausgehen, dass das alles nicht äh äh verfassungskonform ist, dass sie hier eben versuchen, diesem,
diesem Problem oder diesem potenziellen Treiben früher Einhalt gebieten,
indem sie's auch noch quasi die Durchführung von Bundesdatenschutzbeauftragten prüfen lassen. Ja.
Auch das ein sehr zähes Thema. Wie gesagt, wer den Hintergrund äh nochmal dazu hören möchte, Lokbuch-Freiheit, die Folge ist verlinkt. Die Überlegung ist ja immer, also der verteidigt wird diese Anwendung damit, dass man sagt, ja das ist ja nur, um,
um dir zu helfen, ne? Wir machen das ja unter der Annahme, dass du,
Das ist deine Angaben bestätigt und dann ist das ja alles super, ist ja auch in deinem Interesse.
Aber was das natürlich eigentlich bedeutet, ist, dass das hier halt eine massive Durchleuchtung der Privatsphäre stattfindet und den Leuten es natürlich zur Last gelegt wird, wenn sie das nicht mitmachen,
Und äh hier eben wieder eine Privatsphäredurchleuchtung, im Prinzip auf die äh Schwächsten stattfindet. Wie gesagt,
die Lea Beckmann kann das sehr viel besser erläutern und begründen, weil sie Juristin ist und deswegen ist da nochmal unser ähm.
Unsere Lokbuchfreiheit folge zu verlinkt.
Mit der Serie läuft das noch?
Ich glaube, wir haben da äh wir haben da irgendwie einfach irgendwann nicht mehr weitergemacht. Es war dann so der das Ende des ersten Lockdowns. Man durfte wieder raus und dann haben wir
so ein bisschen äh einschlafen lassen. Es kam ja auch das Sommerloch so, ne, da gab's weniger zu berichten
an der Front und dann haben wir es nicht wieder aufgenommen bisher. Das soll nicht ausschließen, dass wir es nicht trotzdem irgendwann wieder aufnehmen, wenn's äh spannende, neue Sachen zu berichten,
aber im Moment äh haben wir da keinen regelmäßigen Tournuss, so würde ich das, glaube ich, beschreiben.
Alles klar. So, noch weitere spannende sexy Rechtsthemen haben wir äh am Start für euch. Da steht ja so richtig drauf, oder? Gibt's dazu.
Bestandsdatenauskunft. Wir wir hatten ja eine äh dass ähm also wir hatten das Telekommunikationsgesetz.
Und einige Regeln des Bundes zur Bestandsdatenauskunft, in denen die Bestandsdatenauskunft viel zu,
weitgehend wahr, ja? Weil, und das wurde vom äh Bundesverfassungsgericht für Verfassungswidrig erklärt, weil.
Das Telekommunikationsgeheimnis durch diese Bestandsdatenauskunft und die informatielle Selbstbestimmung durch diese Datenauskunft zu sehr ausgehöhlt werden. So
Warum ist das so krass? Weil also Bestandsdaten sagt man, ja, steht für die,
den Bestandsdatensatz, deinen Account-Daten bei dem äh bei den Betreibern und jetzt dem gegenüber hast du,
ja was weiß ich, die Verkehrsdaten, das wäre jetzt eine tatsächliche Kommunikation. Und wenn man jetzt sagt, ah, wir brauchen nur die Bestandsdaten, dann ist das im Prinzip, wenn immer so gesagt, der ist ja nur so die Anschluss,
Feststellung. Da wurden aber eben viel weitere äh Informationen mit drin aufgenommen, inklusive irgendwie Passwörter und sonstigen, die eben.
Dann zurecht vor dem Bundesverfassungsgericht.
Gekippt wurden. So, jetzt hat der mussten sie also ein Reparaturgesetz machen, weil,
das Alte Gesetz, die die alte Praxis als äh nicht Gesetzeskonform.
Ähm fest abgeurteilt wurde. So und jetzt äh hat.
Haben sie einen neuen, ein neues Gesetz vorgelegt, ja, das offenbar wieder Probleme hat. Ich zitiere dazu mal Klaus Landefeld aus der Stellungnahme des Eco. Klaus Landefeld kennen wir ja, war bei uns äh bei unserer letzten Live-Sendung zu Gast.
Klaus sagt dazu, in der jetzigen Form verdient das Gesetz den den Namen Reparaturgesetz nicht, weil es die entscheidenden Punkte eben nicht repariert, sondern sogar neuen Nachbesserungsbedarf,
schafft, also maßgebliche Vorgaben des Bundesverfassungsgerichts äh werden einfach nicht berücksichtigt. Ähm.
Gleichermaßen würden Telekommunikations- und Telemediendienstanbieter verpflichtet werden, sämtliche unternehmensinterne Daten zur Verfügung zu stellen, um Ermittlungs- und Strafverfolgungsbehörden Informationen zu Passwörtern und anderen Zugangsdaten zu liefern.
Ja? Und damit äh ist ja, also wenn du jetzt das Passwort rausrücken musst, verpflichtest du erstens die Anbieter zur zur, ja, nicht äh
Standardgerecht und wahrscheinlich auch nicht rechtskonform Speicherung von Passwörtern und äh außerdem eben zum Zugang auf dieses Konto und damit äh auf die Identität, dass also völlig irrsinnig die Herausgabe von Passwörtern zu verlangen.
Und mit denen kommst du ja dann auch an die Kommunikationsinhalte. Und wir haben ja nun mal die Trennung zwischen Bestandsdaten und Kommunikationsinhalten nicht umsonst, ja? Also völliger Unsinn. Das Spannende ist, der Bundesrat,
hat dieses Gesetz jetzt in seiner übrigens tausendsten Sitzung nicht akzeptiert.
Also der die der Bundesrat hat gesagt, nee, das wollen wir so nicht. Und jetzt.
Bleibt der Weg in den Vermittlungsausschuss, wo dann eben Bundesrat und Bundestag darüber diskutieren, wie sie mit diesem äh Gesetz umgehen möchten
Jetzt merken aber die Anwälte vom Eco außerdem an, dass dieses Gesetz der Notifizierungspflicht unterliegt. Von der Notifizierungspflicht haben wir jetzt schon äh kürzlich einmal drüber gesprochen,
Notifizierungspflicht ist wenn du als europäischer Mitgliedsstaat.
Verabschieden möchtest, die die Dienste der Informationsgesellschaft betreffen. Wenn ich das jetzt ungefähr,
richtig zusammengefasst habe. Und dieser Notifizierungspflicht unterliegt auch das IT-Sicherheitsgesetz, was der Grund war, warum die,
Stellungnahmenspflicht für das IT-Sicherheitsgesetz so kurz war, weil die das noch unbedingt einreichen mussten, um diese Notifizierungspflichtgenüge zu tun, um es am Ende der Legislatur jetzt noch verabschieden zu können. Äh.
Und eben dieser Notifizierungspflicht unterliegt dieses Gesetz zur Reparatur der Bestandsdatenauskunft ebenfalls und die Bundesregierung vertritt aber die.
Die Ansicht, dass das nicht so schlimm wäre, weil sie ja die alte Version schon mal vorgelegt haben. Und die neue ist ja nur eine geänderte davon.
Wir beschließen jetzt einfach was anderes als letzte Mal, aber müssen wir euch doch nicht sagen, wie es ist.
Kennt er, hat er ja schon letzte Mal gesagt, ist in Ordnung, wir haben jetzt nur geändert.
Aber ihr habt ja schon gesagt, ist in Ordnung. Also das ist ein Kuddelmuddel. Wenn du dir das anguckst, ja, ist das jetzt irgendwie der der Eco die Bundesregierung, darüber aufklärt,
Hier, äh hier, das ist wunderschön. Der Entwurf ist gegenüber der EU-Kommission als technische Vorschrift gemäß der Richtlinie zwanzig fünfzehn Schrägstrich fünfzehn fünfunddreißig zu notifizieren. Die Regelung des,
ursprünglichen Gesetzesentwurf zur Bekämpfung äh wurden inhaltlich verändert. Diese Regelungen sind erneut zu notifizieren. Und damit,
letztlich der gesamte Gesetzesentwurf, da alle enthaltenen Norm technische Vorschriften sind. Ansonsten ist das Gesetz nach Auffassung des Eco nichtig. Vergleiche Entscheidungen des EuGH zum deutschen Leistungsschutzrecht. Oh, das ist alles schön.
Äh jetzt streiten die sich nicht auch darüber.
Sag mal, gibt's eigentlich irgendeinen anderen rechtspolitischen Bereich, der ähnlich wie das immer bei, wenn's um,
Daten, Auskunft, Vorratsdatenspeicherung, Terror, Daten, Speicherung, Polizeizugriff, also immer wenn's in diesem rechtspolitischen Umfeld unterwegs ist, haben wir
am laufenden Meter seit Jahren und Jahrzehnten immer wieder diese diesen Zyklus. Bundesregierung schlägt was vor, umstritten
dann wird's beschlossen
dann wird dagegen geklagt, Verfassungsgericht, am Ende sagt, ja, nee, so könnte ja äh das aber nicht machen. Dann geht's wieder zurück. Dann wird eine neue Version vorgeschlagen. Die ist wieder umstritten. Dann wird sie wieder beschlossen, dann geht's wieder also
am laufenden Meter, als als ob man in diesem ganzen rechtspolitischen Bereich nicht auch einmal was machen kann, wo man vielleicht mal vorher reinschaut, was
eigentlich unser Staat da so vorgesehen hat oder was auch auf EU-Ebene, weil das läuft ja jetzt im Prinzip auf EU-Ebene genauso weiter, ja?
Ne? Und ich finde es einfach, ich will da jetzt keine Verschwörungstheorie draus drehen, aber ich finde das einfach unangenehm.
Dass dass sie offensichtlich überhaupt gar kein,
Streben gibt hier auch wirklich mal mit der Zivilgesellschaft auf einen Kompromiss sich zu einigen Richtlinien sich zu einigen, die irgendwie mal hält für eine Weile
oder wo zumindest mal Gesetze gemacht werden, die nicht danach gleich wieder von den allerhöchsten Gerichten totgetreten werden.
Ja, vor allem wenn du wenn du sagst, wir betrachten jetzt mal dein Passwort als Bestandsdaten,
und wir hätten gerne dein Passwort, der muss doch, der kann doch wirklich nicht so also da muss doch irgendeiner aufm Flur mal sagen, ey Leute.
Hör doch mal selber, hör doch mal selber.
Und ich möchte nur ganz kurz diese Notifizierungspflicht nochmal erläutern. Also die besteht gemäß der Richtlinie des Europäischen Parlamentes und des Rates
Über ein Informationsverfahren auf dem Gebiet der technischen Vorschriften und der Vorschriften für die Dienste der Informationsgesellschaft. Und in dem Fall, also wenn du.
Eine technische Vorschrift oder eine Vorschrift für die Dienste der Informationsgesellschaft machst, dann.
Müssen musst du als Mitgliedsstaat eben,
Kommission vorliegen und da die Zeit äh äh von, ich glaube, zwei oder drei Monaten.
Überblicken, dass die sagen können, das finden wir. Also du musst es vorlegen, notifizieren.
So, darüber in Kenntnis setzen, dass du das machen möchtest. Und dann äh können die sich eben dazu äh äußern.
Das ist äh diese diese EU-Gesetztexte sind natürlich auch nicht so einfach, weil ja dann auch noch so formuliert sind, dass sie in alle alle Sprachen da übersetzt werden können, äh entsprechend haben die immer nicht das einfachste Deutsch
Deutsch, aber ja, dass diese Notifizierungspflicht,
sei erwähnt. Also auch da fahren sie wieder völlig vor die Wand und das Lustige ist, du hast jetzt hier eben diese Abhängigkeiten, was ich gerade schon kurz erwähnte, dass es.
Hier die das Gesetz zur Regelung der Bestandsdatenauskunft ist und dass diese Reparatur dafür ist jetzt.
Quasi auch die Pendencys in dem Hate Speech-Gesetz, was jetzt noch quasi noch nicht in Deutschland unterzeichnet ist, weil es eben die Pendenzies auf diese Bestandsdaten ausgeruft hat. Das ist alles,
Da willst du auch nicht arbeiten. Da willst du lieber in der Opposition sein und sagen, finde ich alles blöd.
Wir haben's nicht gemacht. Na ja.
Okay, also da äh Bestandsdaten, das ist wirklich äh.
Weiteres Fass ohne Boden.
Ja und es ist wirklich auch so unsinnig, also Passwörter als Bestandsdaten abzufangen, völlig verrück,
völlig verrückt. Während während du äh während du im Zweifelsfall als Bundesdatenschutzbeauftragter äh oder als ähm.
Zivilrechtler, ein Unternehmen, was Passwörter im Klartext speichert, wahrscheinlich äh äh sofort äh verurteilen würdest, ne, wegen äh unsachgemäßer Fahrlässigkeit äh
und verstoß gegen sämtliche Sicherheitsstandards, die sich in den letzten die sich Leute ausgedacht haben, bevor es Computer gab, so, ne? Na gut, äh lassen wir.
Du kennst aber bestimmt dieses schöne alte Pressefoto, wo so Honecker und und noch ein paar andere von seinen getreuen so mitm,
Weinglas in der Hand, prustend so zusammenstehen
Einer sagt irgendwas. Dann habe ich gesagt, lass uns doch einfach die Passworte als Bestandsdaten deklarieren.
Und alle schmeißen sich weg. Ja geil, das machen wir. Das ist geil. Das merken die nie.
So
Na ja, dann haben wir noch eine kurze Meldung ähm.
Und zwar wehrt sich ja Reporter ohne Grenzen schon seit zweitausenddreizehn gegen die
Massenüberwachung des Bundesnachrichtendienstes. Äh wir erinnern uns die Neuauflagen PND-Gesetze, was da nicht alles äh zur Folge hatte, ne? Also das sind ja hier noch die Snowden,
ähm nach wehen, wo die Snowden Enthüllungen äh zu
Missständen geführt, äh Missstände offenbart haben und die Erkenntnis der
Bundesregierung war, oh mein Gott, das Gesetz verstößt gegen die Geheimdienste. Dann wohl das BND-Gesetz so geändert, dass alles, was vorher verboten war, jetzt legalisiert wurde
und äh der,
die Reporter ohne Grenzen und andere NGOs klagen gegen das BND-Gesetz und jetzt äh wurde die,
die Beschwerde von äh Reporter ohne Grenzen vom Gerichtshof in Straßburg akzeptiert. Insofern.
Muss sich der BND.
Jetzt vom Gerichtshof im Straßburg rechtfertigen. Das ist erstmal spannend für seine strategische Fernmeldeaufklärung. Das wird natürlich schon äh relativ lange dauern, bis das wieder passiert, aber.
Schauen wir mal. Das wird spannend werden.
Aber auch das, ne? Ich meine, das ist Engagement von äh seit zwanzig dreizehn, ja und man kann davon ausgehen,
äh dass äh eine Entscheidung nicht äh in diesem Jahr erfolgt, ne.
Ein bisschen dauern, ja.
Bereits am neunten Dezember wurde die Beschwerde an die Bundesregierung zugestellt, nachdem die Frist für eine gütliche Einigung am vierten März endet, hat die Bundesregierung zwölf Wochen Zeit innerlich Stellung zu beziehen. Und dann.
Dann dann liegt, dass es dann erstmal nur Papier stand.
Tja. Und dann wird, wird eine Entscheidung quasi dort neun Jahre später erwartet.
Neun, oh Mann.
Ja, wenn die zwanzig dreizehn angefangen haben damit. Ja, kannst du Karrieren drauf bauen.
Leute, geht in die Politik, da könnt ihr was bewegen. Das.
Ja, irgendwann.
Gehört ja wie wie Patrick Breyer, ja, der jetzt auch seit äh über einem Jahrzehnt äh die Vorratsdatenspeicherung begleitet. Ne, kannst du machen, super.
Da geht da geht dir so da wirst du so schnell dich mit deinem Projekt fertig. Wie so ein wie so ein Karriereist in der freien Wirtschaft. Da musste, da musste deine Projekte in in einem Jahr fertig haben.
Ab Ohrout, ja, aber dann kannst du dich woanders bewerben, ja. Hier hast du solide Arbeitgeber.
Solide Karrieremöglichkeiten. Einen Missstand und du kannst dein Leben dran rumkauen.
Wie heißt das.
Hat auch was für sich.
Patrick Beier zeigt das ja immer wieder schön.
Ja, er hat natürlich sich jetzt er berichtet auch äh die Missstände aus der äh ähm aus der Schwächung der E-Privacy äh Richtlinie. Wir erinnern uns, da soll die,
E-Privacy-Richtlinie aufgeweicht werden.
Um im weiteren Verlauf dann das, was in der in der E-Privacy Richtlinie dann erlaubt wird, was vorher verboten war. In zweiter Stelle dann eben auch gesetzlich verpflichtend zu machen. Und da haben sich jetzt,
gerade EU-Regierung auf eine Position geeinigt äh und die ist natürlich äh.
Dass diese Schwächung stattfinden soll, ja? Und im Prinzip eine freiwillige, eine Vorratsdatenspeicherung, ein.
Tracking. Zuerst mal überhaupt zu legalisieren, ja? Äh was eben nach der ePrivacy-Richtlinie nicht möglich wäre,
und
wie gesagt, hier geht es in der Schwäche der E-Privacy-Richtlinie, die muss vorgenommen werden, damit du es nachher verpflichtend machen kannst. Im Moment hast du es durch die E-Privace-Richtlinie grundsätzlich verboten, ja? Und äh das ist, wie gesagt, nur der erste Streich und deswegen muss da hier,
Patrick hat das ja bei uns auch schon äh ausführlich und besser, als ich das jetzt noch kann, erklärt. Auch die Folge verlinken wir noch einmal. Aber da geht also im Moment alles noch weiter in der Richtung, die,
uns damals schon dargelegt wurde oder.
Vorausgedacht wurde und ja, es geht es geht den Weg, ja. Klang damals noch wie eine Verschwörungstheorie.
Ist aber morgen schon auf unserer Showbühne.
Das ist so im besten neunzehnvierundachtzig spricht, ne, Überwachung ist Privatsphäre.
Tja. Oh je. Okay, ich bin ein bisschen durch. Das unkontrollierte war der der Sendungstitel. Äh als Patrick das uns nochmal alles in Ruhe erklärt hat.
Ja, du bist ein bisschen durch, ich auch. Ähm aber,
So ist es manchmal. Manchmal gibt's einfach nur äh trockenes Programm hier bei Politik, das verdichten wir dann auch extra in so eine Sendung, damit wir dann die anderen ein bisschen lockerer gestalten können.
Programm und äh muss ja auch sagen, wir sind ja oder ich zumindest unterliege ja äh den Notwendigkeiten und äh Widrigkeiten.
Dass ich noch für mein Geld arbeiten muss.
Gott.
Meine Insta, meine Instagrammer Influencer-Karriere. Hebt einfach nur nicht ausreichend ab, ja? Euch äh.
Fällt noch nicht mal eine Info bei ab.
Kann nicht mal, ich bin noch nicht mal Influencer.
Gott.
So und äh.
Ja, gut, aber das ist halt äh die, die, die, die, die Bringschuld, das tritt man sich ja dann halt irgendwie äh ein.
Besondere, äh, wenn man hier so eine, wie soll ich sagen, eine, ähm, du bist ja, sagen wir mal,
eher der redaktionelle äh Arm, der im Vorfeld der Sendung greift. Ich bin der produzierende Arm, der ja im Nachgang der Sendung greift mit äh,
immer wiederkehrenden ähm Rollentauschmomenten. Insofern äh.
Am Ende auch nochmal drauf hinweisen, äh dass ihr uns im,
letzten Jahr in dieser Hinsicht sehr äh geholfen äh habt. Äh das hat auf jeden Fall ähm hier mehr ähm Kapazitäten frei geräumt, ne.
Auch für für dich Linus, ne? Die ich noch mehr auf Lokbuch Netzpolitik zu äh konzentrieren.
Deswegen möchte ich auch nochmal ganz kurz drauf äh hinweisen. Ich hatte dieses Jahr schon vor einigen Wochen mal angesprochen, dass ja diese Kontoumstellung da bei mir äh erforderlich war, dass äh ist jetzt auf den allerletzten
Metern, also gut fünfundneunzig Prozent von euch haben das schon gemacht. Das ist super und total
toll und manche sind auch der Bitte nachgekommen und haben dann ihren Dauerauftrag äh auch noch ein wenig äh der Inflation angepasst. Das freut uns natürlich besonders. Gut fünf Prozent fehlen noch
Also, falls ihr das jetzt das allererste Mal hört, packen wir nochmal kurz einen Link äh auf den Blogbeitrag von mir, wo ich das nochmal kurz erläutere. Kurzfassung ist,
Gibt ein neues Konto und wenn der einen Dauerauftrag gelaufen habt, dann äh ändert doch bitte dieses Konto und dann äh wird auch alles gut.
Mehr gibt's dazu nicht zu sagen eigentlich.
Dann freuen wir uns über Tims äh in wenigen Monaten vollzogenen Kontowechsel.
Na der Wechsel ist schon voll vollzogen. Es müssen nur alle anderen mitziehen.
Müssen nur alle mitmachen, ja, so ähnlich wie äh eine E-Mail-Adresse. Die benutze ich nicht mehr. Du vielleicht nicht.
Genau. Ja Leute, das war's für heute. Mehr gibt's nicht.
Ich würde sagen, ähm wir, also möchten wir hierzu noch eine äh ein Feedback-Call machen oder äh wir sind da im Moment deine Pläne, Tim.
Ach so, ähm wir sind jetzt so ein bisschen zeitlich ein bisschen verrutscht. Wir können gerne nochmal so ein Feedback-Call machen, allerdings weiß ich jetzt grad nicht, was der beste Tag dafür wäre. Ähm.
Mittwoch vielleicht, ja, Mittwoch könnte passen.
Ähm.
Wir machen einfach mal eine Runde auf. Das ist immer äh äh ich bin ehrlich gesagt ein bisschen erstaunt, dass in diesen Feedback-Runden nicht nur jetzt so viele Leute dazugekommen sind, sondern dass auch.
Extrem inhaltlich äh nachgefragt wird. Also man hat fast den Eindruck, ihr hört uns tatsächlich zu.
Also.
Das ist völlig erstaunlich. Also ich meine, man kann ja auf unterschiedliche Arten und Weisen zuhören,
kann das so als Unterhaltung nehmen. So, man kann es äh inhaltlich so zur Bereicherung so, ach ja, solche Sachen gibt's ja auch noch
Aber es gibt auch viele Leute, die die sich wirklich auch einen Kopf machen drum und, und, und, und das Weiterdenken und natürlich auch viele äh im aktiven Umfeld für für die das dann vielleicht auch eine wirklich sinnvolle Ressource ist, um einfach da auf Trab zu
bleiben oder vielleicht auch ein bisschen Motivation daraus zu ziehen, dass wir darüber sprechen. Und das kam irgendwie gut rüber
So, also ich denke, das ist schon so ein so ein Element, was man auf die ein oder andere Art und Weise beibehalten muss. Ob wir das hinten dann auf der Plattform so beibehalten werden, das wissen wir nicht, aber diese ganze,
bin Audiogeschichte, ist ja auch noch relativ neu, das entwickelt sich. Äh das müssen wir nochmal sehen, aber so wie's bisher äh läuft, finde ich das
gut. Ob wir das jetzt jede Woche so durchhalten können, weiß ich noch nicht, aber derzeit ist es einfach sehr interessant.
Ja, also von mir aus legt das für Mittwoch später abends an, dann können wir das nochmal machen. Mittelfristig bin ich aber jetzt auch
wirklich an dem Punkt, da also es muss dann eine Plattform sein, zu der auch alle Zugang haben können, da müssen wir man liest ja jetzt das äh Twitter und Facebook so etwas äh in Windeseile nachbauen.
Ja ja, alle werden das jetzt bauen und es gibt da ja auch schon ein paar andere Konkurrenten. Die sind bloß alle noch nicht so weit.
Ja, sobald es da eine äh.
Vergleichbare Lösungen mit voller Verfügbarkeit für alle gibt, äh wechseln wir da sofort hin. Im Moment ist, glaube ich, die Befürchtung, es gibt natürlich
Komponentinnen von und anderem, da ist es aber tatsächlich so, da hast du einfach, das darfst du einfach nur eine andere Einstiegshürde.
Für andere Leute. Ähm,
ob ob das jetzt ist die Einstiegshürde ist, dass du ausgerechnet das richtige Betriebssystem hast oder äh dass du irgendwie in der Lage bist, so ein Mumble Setup hinzukriegen, das sind beides
ja, im Prinzip ist das Abitur, ne, es ist beides, äh produziert Ausschlüsse
und äh ja, die Suche ist nach der Lösung, die.
Niedrigschwelligst zugänglich ist, äh saubere,
sauberes Bühne, Zuhörer, Management ermöglicht und äh ja dann eben auch allgemein verfügbar ist mit der niedrigsten,
mit den einfachsten Möglichkeiten, das ist dann eben nun mal eine eine Mobile Phone Lösung im Zweifelsfalle. Und sobald es da etwas gibt mit weiterer Verbreitung, werden wir ja sofort hinwechseln. Oder weitere äh Unterstützung.
Und was uns auch nicht zu viel weitere Arbeit noch,
kostet, das muss man ja auch nochmal bedenken. Also wir haben jetzt relativ viel Zeit da in diese Runden gesteckt, ich glaube mit Julia waren wir irgendwie auch fast drei Stunden am Quatschen, ne. Das ist äh schon enorm,
war's jetzt auf jeden Fall auch wert, aber das ist, wie gesagt, alles ein Prozess und wir gucken halt einfach mal, was was da so geht, weil wir wollen ja ein Gefühl dafür bekommen, was noch so passieren müsste.
Es gibt ja auch, also ich sage da auch ganz persönlich noch was zu. Ich hänge gerade den größeren Teil meiner Zeit mit einem Headset am Computer und bin in irgendwelchen Calls und irgendwelchen Teams und haste nicht gesehen und,
äh das alles schön und gut, aber ich bin eben nicht bereit, jetzt da nebenbei noch irgendeinen Mumblet Server zu administrieren oder sowas, ne? Und diese
dass es auf einem mobilen Endgerät funktioniert, hat eben für mich auch den Vorteil, dass ich das dann einfach mal mit einem Bluetooth Headset in einer in einem entspannteren Setting machen kann.
Und das äh ist für mich auch so ein bisschen etwas, was jetzt ja ging äh kompliziertere Lösungen spricht.
So sieht's aus. Das war's von uns äh für heute und wir entlassen euch hiermit wieder in die äh in dies freies Fähre eurer Medienauswahl. Bis bald.
Tschau, tschau.